معنا من مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس مراسل
الجزيره مؤمن الشرافي مؤمن قربنا اكثر من
المشهد الانساني والميداني في قطاع
غزه نعم محمود قبل قليل المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وايضا طائرات مسيره اسرائيليه
فتحت نيران اسلحتها الرشاشه وايضا اطلق
جيش الاحتلال عدد من القذائف الصاروخيه
اتجاه تجمع
للمواطنين قرب عماره جاسر وسط مدينه خان
يونس وصل حتى هذه اللحظه الى مجمع ناصر
شهيد وعدد كبير من الاصابات في صفوف
المواطنين والحديث هناك يدور عن وجود عدد
من الشهداء في المنطقه نتيجه القصف
المدفعي الاسرائيلي وايضا
اطلاق اعيره ناريه من قبل طائرات مسيره
اسرائيليه اتجاه المواطنين في تلك المنطقه
ايضا تدور اشتباكات نسمع دوي انفجارات
كبيره نتيجه استمرار القصف المدفعي
الاسرائيلي الذي يستهدف مناطق عده في وسط
مدينه خانيونس الى جانب اشتباكات تدور في
المحور الشرقي والشمالي من المدينه بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى وسط قطاع غزه وتحديدا في
مخيم المغازي ارتفع عدد الشهداء نتيجه
القصف الاسرائيلي الذي استهدف منزل عائله
القريناوي في مخيم المغازي الى خمس
شهيدا وعشرات الاصابات التي وصلت الى
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى من بين الاصابات بحسب
المصادر الطبيه عدد منها مصابون بجروح
خطيره نتيجه قصف هذا المنزل الماهول
بالسكان ودون سابق انذار وتدميره على رؤوس
ساكنيه بالاضافه الى قصف مدفعي يستهدف
ايضا مخيم البريج وايضا مخيم النصيرات
اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من محيط محطه توليد
الكهرباء في شمال مخيم النصيرات نتيجه
غارات جويه استهدفت اراض زراعيه محيطه
بمحطه الكهرباء ايضا في مخيم البريج هناك
عدد كبير من النازحين محاصرين تحاصرهم
قوات الاحتلال داخل مدارس تابعه لانر وهي
مراكز للواء لا يستطيعون الدخول او حتى
الخروج من هذه المدارس وسط مناشدات من قبل
النازحين للامم المتحده والصليب الاحمر
بضروره التدخل لفتح ممر انساني لاجلاء من
تلك المنطقه التي تحاصرها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وايضا تدور اشتباكات في
الاطراف الشرقيه وايضا الشماليه من المخيم
بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي كتائب القسام قالت انها اوقعت
قوه راجله اسرائيليه في كمين محكم داخل
احد المنازل شرق مخيم البريج وانها
استهدفت هذه القوى بالقذائف الصاروخيه
وايضا با اطلاقات ناريه واوقعت هذه القوى
بين قتيل وجريح بحسب اعلان كتائب الشهيد
عز الدين القسام بالاضافه الى غارات امتدت
الى منطقه جحر الديك وايضا الاحياء
الجنوبيه من مدينه غزه ايضا رغم الانسحاب
التدريجي لقوات الاحتلال من حي النصر
وايضا منطقه الامن العام والاحياء
الشماليه الغربيه وشمال مخيم الشاطئ في
مدينه غزه فالا ان المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
المتمركزه في عدد من المناطق في مدينه غزه
استهدفت مختلف الاحياء في المدينه بقصف
مدفعي عشوائي استهدفت منازل المواطنين ما
اوقع عدد من الشهداء والجرحى وفي شمال
القطاع لا تقل الامور سوء عما يدور في
مدينه غزه او في الوسط وفي الجنوب قصف
مدفعي وايضا غارات جويه استهدفت منطقه بئر
النعجه في غرب
مخيم جباليا ادت هذا ادت هذه الغارات الىى
استشهاد سته فلسطين نسمع تحليق مكثف
لطائرات حربيه اسرائيليه يبدو انها اخترقت
حاجز الصوت هنا في مدينه خان يونس وسط
القصف وايضا المدفع والاشتباكات التي تدور
في المحور الشرقي والشمالي من المدينه
ويبدو ان هذا اليوم هو الاكثر ضراوه من
ناحيه الاشتباكات المسلحه في عدد من محاور
القتال والاشتباك بين رجال المقاومه قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي تحاول التقدم
اكثر الى عمق مدينه خانيونس نعم مؤمن في
مراسل الجزيره شكرا جزيلا لك كان معنا من
خان يونس